okay great so um
one of the major goals in my lab is to
understand disease mechanisms and
improve health
through precise measurements on human
bodies and not just on the human cells
in the body but also on the microbial
cells
it live in our gut on our skin in our
respiratory tracts and throughout many
of the organs of our bodies and
there's mounting evidence that including
microbes and precision medicine can do
important things like
better predict uh
what doses of drugs we should take and
whether those drugs would have adverse
side effects
and there are many companies here in the
bay area and worldwide that are trying
to use the microbiome in therapeutic
development
um this is a very large-scale omics
problem the precise measurements of the
microbiome are usually done by
sequencing often dna sometimes rna
sometimes metabolites are proteins
but let's just talk about dna if we take
a sample we get
millions of short sequences often it's
150 base pair paradigm sequencing and in
here there's going to be a mixture of
hundreds of species
to figure out what's there it these seek
short sequencing greeds get compared to
large databases currently with hundreds
of thousands of genomes in them each on
average say five million base pairs
and
long
we and many others write code that's
going to search for matches basically
um
and uh this is hard for a number of
reasons one of them is that uh when this
field got started
for
the human gut microbiome 50 or less of
the species weren't present in the
databases so anything that's not in the
database is invisible
um through some efforts i'll briefly
describe that's down much lower now
the other problem is that this search is
very intense this is much more
computation
than uh say doing an rna-seq experiment
on a human sample
we're uh lucky enough to have access to
some cloud computing through the chan
zuckerberg biohub we're going along
doing our work and got the attention
believe it or not of mark zuckerberg who
said my computer bill was too big
and that he didn't want to pay it
anymore
and so um
we were
doing something about like around ten
thousand dollars a month of computing at
that time
that is not fair it's not
fair perhaps that mark zuckerberg has to
pay my bill but more importantly it's
not fair because it's not democratic it
means only someone like me who has a lot
of resources can do these analyses
why am i blowing that amount of money
anyway and even if it was useful to
science that i was blowing that amount
of money it means that most of the world
can't do these analyses
so i'm going to show you that we got
some of these analyses to run on a
laptop computer so solving the
computational problem
the third problem which is the main
thing i want to talk about today is
that the analyses are very biased and
give very misleading results
in particular when there are closely
related species in the database they
completely confound all the short read
aligners like bow tie bwa mini map
and those
incorrect alignments lead to bias
downstream statistics
i do not have a magic bullet for this
one it's something we're still working
on and i
welcome your input and i hope others
will be interested in thinking about it
with me but i will show you some
mitigation strategies that we've
developed
so the talk is mostly about alerting
anyone who's doing this kind of work and
also anyone who's not has feedback about
it to this problem but i will also talk
about some of the other stuff
now
most people who've heard about
microbiome science and maybe some of you
have done some are probably thinking
about just figuring out which microbes
are there and how much of each one
and uh that is what most microbiome
papers do
uh it's my opinion that that is not
particularly useful for precision
medicine because two strains of the same
species
something that would be put in the same
chunk of this pie chart can have vastly
different functional capabilities
um they can heart you know one could be
pathogenic and one not
one of them can have uh create an
anti-inflammatory metabolite one might
not one of them can inactivate your
cancer drug and the other one might not
um and we're all kind of aware of that
in this world today of covid variants
that like every time there's new
variants they're all covered stuff
they're all still stars cove too but um
they're the function in terms of things
like important things like
transmissibility
and pathogenicity is evolving over time
so we tend to not do these pie charts
what we do is something much more
precise but also much more
computationally intensive which is to
analyze the samples
at a strain level
by calling genetic variants in the short
reads
and this doing this is what alerted me
to this problem with closely related
species in the database so i'll tell you
a little bit about it
um
because it's the context for our work
but i think the problem i'm going to
share with you is much broader than this
genotyping problem so what do i mean by
genetic variants in the short reads for
one species in this test tube
one place in its genome within that
stool sample you could have a mixture of
strains and so maybe 70 of the reeds
here carry one variant and then there's
this g that's present in 30 of the reeds
so that's within sample genetic
variation there can be between
sample genetic variation either from the
same community like sample from the same
person but six months later or just two
completely different people or two
completely different environments and i
should say
i work on the human microbiome primarily
on stool samples
but what i'm saying applies to any kind
of environmental sequencing studies so
if you're studying soil or water in the
ocean the same would apply
so you can do this genotyping
to find the short reads we take
metagenomic sequencing we align it with
tools like bowtie which is what i'm
going to talk about today but none of
this is specific to bow tie
we align it to a reference database
and instead of saying how many reads do
we have for each species and making a
pie chart we just make a pile up and we
call variants like anyone who's familiar
with running like a genotyping pipeline
for humans it's the same idea
we do this iteratively for each species
in the sample
and each position in its genome and we
get these variants you can also look at
the pile up of reeds and compare
coverage to the coverage of universal
single copy genes and estimate the copy
number variants for coding genes as well
but i'm going to focus on single
nucleotide variants
okay and i'm not going to talk at all
about this the fun part is once you have
these you can do some really cool things
like doing gwasps but now with the
microbial variants to host traits you
can study the evolution of the
microbiome you can track strains and ask
whether strange present a baby were
actually in their mother did the baby
get it from somewhere else all kinds of
fun stuff
but i'm not going to talk about that
today um happy to discuss later
okay so first i'm going to talk about
something i'm calling challenge zero
because this is sort of like an old
problem that's been solved for a few
years now but just just some background
because this was kind of an important
thing
a big problem a few years ago was that
many species are invisible to this
process because they're not in the
database
we developed a method using universal
single copy genes that should be present
in every cellular organism
to calculate how much of the diversity
in a sample is represented in the
database
so if you were to do read alignment to a
database
how much would you see of what was
actually there what proportion and so
you want that to be 100
and you can see for samples from a whole
bunch of natural environments it's
really abysmal it's better for the human
microbiomes
some environments like skin we know
almost all the microbes that are there
because it's a simpler community and
it's been well characterized
human stool has this huge variance you
can see the bar there
and what we showed back in 2016 was just
like in human genetics where there's
been a bias to study europeans and north
americans exact same thing in microbiome
research the database is biased towards
north americans and europeans
so these samples from tanzania and peru
for example had very low database
coverage compared to them ones from the
u.s
europe and also china has sort of joined
the game and in this field at least as
being like
uh
in the database instead of out of the
database
but basically the rest of the world
besides the us um
europe and china is is really poorly was
was really poorly represented in the
database
this launched a huge effort to try to
get better coverage better
representation in the database
and um
while isolation and sculpturing in the
lab is still very biased to certain
geographic regions
the shotgun meta genomic sequencing
where you just get stool samples and
sequence everything in it has been less
biased i wouldn't say unbiased at all
you can see the reddest places on the
graph are still china a few european
countries and the u.s
but there has been sequencing in many
countries on six continents and so we
and others joined in this international
consortium assembled genomes from these
shotgun samples and we've been closing
the gap so this is the amount of gap
closing that's happened and the really
rewarding thing is there's been a lot
more gap closing for the exact places
that were poorly represented in the past
um so it's uh they're still biased but
it has been greatly improved in the last
few years
um and
through efforts like this as well as
single cell sequencing and something
called cultural mix where people try to
grow bugs in the lab that they haven't
been able to grow ever before with some
more advanced microfluidics there are
now genomes for a lot more species than
there were a few years ago there's been
an explosion since 2015.
um this is ncbi assembly which is not
including the metagenome assembled
genomes and then here are three
databases that the uhcg
the gtdb and the gem are ones that use
these metagenomic samples
and the important thing for this talk is
there are now many many species that
have hundreds or even thousands of
genome strains that have a genome
sequence so there's a lot of interest
specific diversity in the database
okay
so more genomes sounds like good news is
it good news
well
for the problem that i initially started
with yes it means now for a human gut
microbiome even one outside of north
america and europe the alignment rate is
much higher so there's less it's not
solved but there's less of these
invisible species and there's less of
this
geographic bias
however two new problems arise so i'm
going to talk about both of those
the first one and the main thing i want
to present today this is sort of my my
main point
is that we now have a densely sequenced
tree of life
where many species have a close relative
and what happens when you align short
reads to such a database is the species
are competing for reeds that will not be
news to anyone who's worked on like rna
seeds and knows about multi-mapping this
is sort of like multi-mapping on
steroids
because there's multi-mapping within
every species and then also across
species
so this is quantifying the amount of
closely related species the sort of
greener or bluer you know as we move
from yellow to blue on the spectrum
there are more species in each lineage
that have a neighbor that is within 92
to 95 average nucleotide genome-wide 95
is sort of a rough species boundary or
one that's operationally used so these
are things that are just past the
species boundary
um so certain lineages have a lot more
than others
um but the point is that there are
thousands and thousands of pairs of
closely related species now
here's what happens
in theory and then i'll show you the
numbers on real data when you have a
close relative in the database
so the first thing which is probably the
most cryptic one is the reed so dark
purple is like the correct or on target
genome the light purple um or fuchsia is
the off target the closely related
species there's the purple reed getting
aligned the red dots are the snips the
percent identity is shown and then the
outcome is sort of described below so in
this first example it's aligned in fact
it's aligned to the correct species
um but uh the statistics that the
aligner calculates um in bow tie that
would be the map idea the score and the
map q which sounds like quality so we
all use it for filtering
the quality of this alignment is a sort
of medium to low because the next best
alignment the second best is almost as
good as the first so map q is the ratio
of the best alignment score to the next
best alignment score
and so if we were to quality filter even
though this is correctly aligned it
would likely get filtered out
these two
are worse
so the uh the read won't be aligned at
all because there's very close
competition or even perfect you know
exact match between the best and the
second best alignment and then here's
the thing that seems like it shouldn't
happen but it does is the reed can
actually map to the wrong species with a
higher alignment score than the correct
one this is called cross mapping
okay those are all bad
and here is what how much they happen
it's this is a simulation
300 species
in each case the closest neighbor starts
very far away and as you move this
direction across the plot it gets closer
and closer to the species boundary so
your neighbor in the database is getting
closer and closer
and then the color
is how diverse is your species itself
meaning uh the re the see the strain and
the reeds
when it's red is pretty far away from
the strain in the database
whereas here there are the exact same
strain
and so you can see two patterns one is
as close neighbors are really stealing
reeds from the on target genome you can
have as much of half of the reeds going
to the neighbor instead of to the
correct genome
and that happens more often as you get
closer as they get closer which makes
sense and more often when the strain
in the sample is diverged from the thing
in the database so the tanzanian sample
being aligned to the european reference
database for example
um so that's a quantification of how
much this happens um at the alignment
level yeah yeah so
this this spot is going to change
yeah so these are 150 base pair paired
end reads and right now i'm treating
them as individual 150 base power reads
in a minute i'm going to say that using
the paired end on the next slide but
using the pair can help a little bit and
in my conclusion i'm going to say long
rates will help a lot so yeah
absolutely
but there's hardly any
long-range sequencing in this field
right now
it's almost all 150 base per paradigm so
that's what we submitted
yeah
so great point
okay so that's what happens with the
alignment level here's for us when we
use these reads to call genotypes
i'm not showing you precision i'm just
showing you recall here
but when alleles differ
from the reference so you have an
alternative instead of a reference
allele you have a really big degradation
of uh recall your ability to call those
alternative alleles
and that gets worse as it gets more
purple which means as your neighbor is
getting closer so as your neighbor gets
closer and as you're calling alleles
that are not the same as the sequence in
the reference database
we have a pretty low recall there's the
same pattern but not as bad for
reference alleles
there's also bad precision which i'm not
showing you to and it's because of the
cross mapping
so if we want to reduce the cross
mapping we can put a map q filter on
we found a map q of 10 reduces
the cross mapping it improves the
precision but it makes the recall even
worse
so the first one was like no math q
filter at all this is with a map q of
10.
if you say that one of the reads in a
read pair has to have a map queue above
10 but the other one can be even worse
then you can
maintain your precision which i'm not
showing you and you get a bit of your
recall back
this is not great though like these
recall you're missing a lot of snips so
this is what i would call a mitigation
like this is a recommended thing to do
paired in filtering and the map queue of
ken
it's not
a great solution it's it's just the best
that we could come up with essentially
this is like a rock and a hard place
problem
um
but the point here is that the
alternative reals suffer way more than
the reference ones the other thing you
can do is to try to get the species in
the database
that are close relatives out of there if
you don't think they're in the sample
so if you have a close neighbor and you
don't think that's in the sample but you
believe that the organism you're
interested in is in the sample get the
close neighbor out of there that makes
the problem a little bit better
so it doesn't have baton because
sometimes the close neighbor is in the
sample but it can help a little bit so
those are our two mitigation strategies
this is not great news but this is
something we recently published that is
an improvement over what everyone has
been doing
okay so the mitigation strategies help
but basically we need to avoid doing
alignment with the with bow tie so i'm
going to show you another solution we
came up with for our specific problem of
genotyping it may work for some of the
other problems and it avoids doing short
read alignment
the idea is to develop a database of
short probes or k-mers
that
you're going to use instead of alignment
to entire reference genomes and you want
to pick those k-mers so that they are
unique
that they do not
occur in other genomes what we're giving
up on here is that we are now not going
to align g reads to the entire genome
we're going to align them to
like the equivalent of like a genotyping
array but on the computer
rather than say whole genome sequencing
and then calling snips in the pile up
this is like a computational genotyping
array or even like a microarray with
probes on it for people who are familiar
with that you want your probes to be
unique so you don't have cross
hybridization but you're giving up on
like the the quantification and the
genome-wideness of doing rna-seq
okay so we designed these probes by
doing genome comparisons and we put
those probes
through a filter where we're trying to
find out if they're really unique and
occur nowhere else in the database it
doesn't mean they don't occur anywhere
else in nature we cannot guarantee that
but we
guarantee that they've never been seen
to the world before and have been like
all sequencing that's ever been done
but they only occur in that place in
that genome for that species
there are some single nucleotide
variants that have no unique k-mers so
we also have an option for imputing with
ld that i'm not going to talk about
we also at the same time try to solve
the computational problem so this
solution as much not only as i'll show
you more accurate but also faster than
alignment we do that with two things
one is that the k-mer exact matching is
a very efficient algorithm it uses a
prefix filter that's sort of like a
bloom filter
where we look at the first few base
pairs and then only
then we have a collex ordered and a sort
where we can go into this array at a
specific place and not search through
the entire thing linearly and then we
work with an exact match based on suffix
arrays so this is a very efficient
algorithm we also have an efficient data
structure where we don't store all the
k-mers
we store a span around each snip of
where any k-mer could occur and then an
index into that sequence
and we compute on the index and then
only pull out the actual sequences when
we need them
okay all of those things made it uh
about six times more compressed than
bzip2 and as i'll show you much faster
than alignment
so we um you could try different lengths
of k for this application across all
bacteria we found 31 was a good solution
um but the k is actually so this program
the software dynamically chooses k for
you based on your hardware because it
also depends on your hardware
so in terms of like this trade-off of
storage versus compute so if you have a
lot of ram
um it will let you use a bigger k
basically
um
okay
um oh that last point was i'm talking
about short reads like a meta genomic
sample but this exact same strategy can
be used for comparing genomes to each
other assemblies pontigs
unassembled reads okay it's about two
orders of magnitude faster than
alignment
our method is in green
the other methods are all alignment
based except for i'm showing here kraken
2. kraken 2 doesn't do genotyping it
does just like taxonomic composition and
it's also k-mer-based and was part of
our inspiration for this and so i'm
showing it there
just to show another k-mer based method
that solves a different problem
um so we're much faster we do use more
ram
and the reason that this runs on a
laptop
is that we're going to store all this in
the computer ram we're going to operate
on it there
and there's not a lot of like reading
and writing to disk
and so
we use a fair amount of ram but we are
very careful
to choose this number oh gosh it goes
off the screen but it's um well you can
see here for about 40 gigs or for us
about 25 or 30 gigs of ram
so you can run it on on a kind of beefy
laptop
it is also more accurate than the
alignment based method so in gray and
brown or two alignment based methods and
green is our method
has lower false discovery rate and
comparable
power or sensitivity to the other
methods
because it's fast we were able in a
couple of weeks
for a much smaller aws bill to be able
to analyze
seven and a half thousand samples this
is an example of a great deal of data
went into this so each of those samples
is like 50 million reads and we're going
to analyze hundreds of species
for every sample we're going to get a
genotype for every species stack up
those vectors and then say how similarly
related are individuals to each other
based on their microbiomes this is a
genetic relationship of the world
population based on their microbiomes
not on their human dna
either as a heat map or here
as a umap
okay so
unique k-mers beat alignment at known
snvs the last point i want to make
though is that
this method that i just talked about
which is kind of neat
depends on having this like pre-computed
database of snvs it only works for known
snb so now once again anything not in
the database it's going to not it's
going to be invisible to this tool
um
and that is a definitely a problem
so it also means that we have to do this
whole genome multiple sequence alignment
or at least pairwise alignments to
discover the snvs so that's very
computationally intensive how can we
align and call variants in so many
genomes if we have like 300 000 genomes
um tandy talked about the difficulty of
of alignment
today for example
okay so very quickly um
what we did was uh develop an algorithm
to uh pick a subset of all the genomes
so just think about one species now
let's say it has a thousand genomes in
the database i want to pick a subset the
optimization that we're trying to solve
here is a minimal subset of those
genomes that captures as much of the
common genetic variation as possible
so what that means intuitively is you
want to find genomes that are not
related to each other that are sort of
spread out across the space of genetic
diversity of that species
so to do that we're going to cluster all
the genomes and then for each cluster
pick one representative
and i'm not going to have time today to
talk about the algorithm but uh this is
based on doing a fast uh clustering of
the genomes with something called mass
distance which is an approximation of
average nucleotide identity and then
trimming the graph using this algorithm
to find something called a d cut which
is basically like where i'm going to cut
edges out of the graph
once i have those representative genomes
one for each species i can see how much
redundancy was in the database
so here this species a preacher dinos
had
3646 genomes but i only need 46 clusters
and i'll show you in a moment that that
captures most of the genetic variation
for this species in contrast a rectalis
over here didn't compress as much a
little over 5000 genomes i still needed
2 650 clusters so this is a data
adaptive choice of how much to compress
or how much redundancy to move from the
removed from the database
with the goal of still being able to
capture as many snips as possible so
here's the genome the species with 46
clusters snip discovery maxes out pretty
quickly so if we go to 46 we're getting
most of the genetic variation
there's the species with more and it
takes longer to max out to the diversity
of that species and so you're going to
need at least a few hundred clusters
if not more to capture all the genetic
diversity there
i don't think i have time to talk about
this in any detail but we also showed
that using these representative or tag
genomes actually decreases bias
if you want to discover all snips below
a certain minor allele frequency like
one percent in the population but your
database is really biased you have like
300 genomes that are all from the same
hospital outbreak
they're all very closely related to each
other
then you're going to miss estimate the
minor allele frequency you're going to
think anything that's in those genomes
is more common broadly in the population
than it really is
and so what people commonly do is put
pick a math threshold
and what we showed and i won't go over
the graph here but we showed that we
actually have a less biased estimate of
the true set of snips at a given math
frequency
finally this is faster than other
approaches for calling snips in genomes
these two are the competing methods
these are two versions of our method the
competing methods
are slower
um
this is elapsed time they're slower for
500 or a thousand genomes and they fail
on 5000 genomes
whereas ours runs
and um we could then you can run gt pro
or other methods to to genotype those
snips in genomes very fast
so we
can genotype um very quickly like
a large number of stars two genomes or
what i'm showing here is a little over
three thousand um h pylori strains of
bacterium that has really interesting
biogeography across the world
and build a tree like this
cool okay so tag genome speed up variant
discovery they also improve accuracy so
um
it's great that we've been all doing so
much genome sequencing and assembly but
you don't really need the next genome
that's just as similar to a genome
you've seen before we really need to
focus on new lineages and and not
redundant ones because they don't have a
lot of value
and then in some cases can really
confound your analysis
okay so i just wanted to stop and say
like we're happy with the tools that we
built they've just been released you
know they're they're they help this
situation but we have not solved this
problem of short read aligners failing
on big data sets with with big reference
genome databases
so just stepping back a little like from
our own work i just wanted to conclude
with a few thoughts for the field
um we definitely need some different
strategies there are some that are
already out there that many of you know
about or even worked on
um like genome graph algorithms they
would be really useful here right now
they are not fast enough to work with
this much data
similarly probabilistic read mapping
where you know in transcriptomics you
sort of find a multi-mapping read and if
one of the transcripts is looking from
uniquely mapping reads to be very
abundant compared to the other one you
have a higher probability for that
multi-mapping read to go to the other
transcript the same kind of thing would
work really well here
again those algorithms would need to be
much faster to work on this amount of
data
there are some neat methods coming out
where there's no database at all um
julia salsman talked about one of these
in her talk at the first week of this
conference
it has some pre-prints out there's a few
other people thinking along these lines
where you just directly compare reads to
each other no reference database until
you get to the interpretation stage
and then as gian uh
smartly
gathered on like slide two
longer reads or like hablotypes will
also help with things like the cross
mapping problem
in the meantime what we're working on
and what we advise is that tools that do
use things like bowtie
bwa need to be flexibly implemented so
that people can very carefully choose
the thresholds that they're using a
default map queue of 30 which is what
almost all the software out there uses
would would be really in a bad place in
all the graphs that i showed you
so i talked about bacterial communities
um but other microorganisms are also
starting to have very densely sequenced
uh lineages
and as um we also heard
um uh from harris at this meeting many
eukaryotes as well
um so this is not like just a microbiome
problem these uh
it's not a problem specific to the
genotyping that i'm working on but i
think also just any quantification of
abundance of species or genes would
suffer from these problems
and we as databases get bigger and
bigger we all feel good like oh more
data but it's making bioinformatics like
less and less accessible to
the average lab so i think we're all
obligated people like myself who have a
lot of resources i feel obligated to
think about
how to make
cutting edge analysis available to
everyone
so here's my team i want to stand
funding i want to especially acknowledge
to you and jason who did a lot of the
work today thank you very much and i'll
take questions
thanks sir some focus on this co2
footprint
yeah what we do yeah and use that
argument
yeah i know i think about that too ten
thousand dollars but also a lot of co2
yeah there's some nice papers about uh
what
can be done in that space and
bioinformatics recently so questions
here
it's quite amazing i didn't realize this
microbiome compute is so big
for tagging the genomes
like when you have more and more genomes
can you like
gradually add newly tagged genomes or do
you have to go back and revamp
your previous text great question yeah
we have an iterative update that you can
do so you can quickly see if they belong
to an existing cluster
if they don't then you start a new
cluster basically
okay so they either don't become a tag
or they do based on their similarity to
the existing and that's a quick
relatively quick compute because you're
not comparing to all genomes just to the
tags
anderson great talk katie and
um
more of a biological question i guess
for
um the cases where you have see
use a lot of clusters to represent like
a gene because there are a lot of
symptoms do you tend to see clinical
correlates of
strain you like do you tend to see more
often that those
more diverse genes are more correlated
with disease really good question so
like i had that quick slide at the
beginning of like the fun part and what
i really want to be working on is
associating all this with phenotypes
either of the microbes or the hosts um
yes when there's a lot of genetic
diversity there is more opportunity for
strain specific associations with things
like drug response and phenotypes
there's also more power
so there's two things i think there's
biological reality of like more genetic
diversity more opportunity
for phenotypic differences between
strains
but there's also in general like more
data more power so both of those come
into play so we in our association
studies tend to focus on a much smaller
set of like
30 to 50 species where we have good
power and there's a lot of diversity
just for first pass low hanging fruit
kind of thing yeah
so from there from the practical
standpoint so how really relevant is
this problem of assigning the correct
rate
to the correct
neighborhood species in terms of
functional implications very similar
species are going to have
similar impacts right so and for broad
taxonomic characterization of the
metagenomic samples
probably
this is i mean i mean how important is
really this in the practice that
i'm pretty sure that there are cages in
which this is
crucial but i have not really yeah
thanks for the question it's a commonly
held belief um that
uh
that uh you know
maybe even out to the like phylum level
that things are functionally similar to
each other and certainly at like a genus
level like a lot of microbiome analysis
is done at the genus level and it's
assumed you just need a pie chart of how
much of each genus and you can associate
that with traits
they've actually not been very many
replicated associations and there are
some
there are almost no mechanistic
associations at say a genus or a family
or an order level like no one can
explain why
on the other hand there are many
examples where two strains of the same
species have a different phenotype so e
coli is in all of us but only some of it
causes food poisoning yeah you can think
of many examples so i think i have a
particular and biased point of view but
i think there is a great deal of genetic
variation below the species level we've
quantified that so for the human gut
microbiome two people
living in the same city and say europe
or the us or china we can ask what
percent if they both have the same
species what percentage of the genes do
they share
that varies across bacterial species
but for some of them it's as low as 40
percent so we call them the same species
but sixty percent of their genes are
different
and so there can of course then be a lot
of functional differences so
on the other hand there are some i
showed you the one with only four you
know thousands of genomes in only 46
clusters that one's pretty clonal so for
that one it doesn't matter so much
so it's kind of a biological question
and there's and it depends on the
bacterium
does that answer for you
katie
first thank you fantastic talk
um i'm i'm curious about
you know getting to ground truth and
especially errors in
the
sort of annotation databases so e coli
and shigella are a good example yeah
like it's a mess i mean it's just an
absolute mess and so
you know um
as you try to go and take this into
clinical implementations we've seen so i
was part of a group that was doing like
metagenomic sequencing ab initio as a
way to detect infections turns out to be
a really tough if not ill post problem
right so
and it starts with this but then it you
know there's all these other issues
about what do you expect what are the
priors i'd love to get your thoughts on
on
how to think about that problem
particularly when you know the kind of
stuff that joe does right like you don't
know what the infection is right and you
have to have sort of some threshold in
thinking about how to detect and then
you find something is it pathogenic or
not so totally totally
um in a way what you're talking about is
the same problem that things you know
even when you get down here to like
species nodes they have close neighbors
there isn't really a species boundary
you just have a cluster of genomes and a
like a spectrum of phenotypes across all
of those um so it's sort of related to
this but my perspective on what we need
to do clinically
is uh kind of like these probes in my
like virtual genotyping array i think we
need biomarkers that are unique and
identifiable and are clinically
associated so what those are likely to
be is like gene sequences for example
where it is the pathway it is the enzyme
that inactivates the drug okay test for
the enzyme who cares what bacterium it's
in because it's probably getting
horizontally transferred anyway
just test for the enzyme or even for
like the active site of the enzyme with
like some kind of a pcr probe basically
which is not unlike
what the bacteriologist have done for 30
years like let's still look for the
plasmid if it's got a drug resistance
plasmid right kind of does you know
right it doesn't matter where it came
from right we're going to still treat it
exactly
yeah and also i mean a lot of the not
all but many of the ways that bacteria
interact with host are through uh
secreted things like metabolites or
protein from peptides so maybe you just
want to test for those rather than the
bacteria so
same for therapeutics there's a lot of
startup companies in the bay area trying
to make cocktails of specific bacteria
if we knew
that it was like a particular metabolic
pathway that was making an
anti-inflammatory compound like let's
just give the metabolite you know
so my feeling is i guess it's maybe like
a little head of where knowledge is but
we need to focus on those clinically
actionable things rather than on
taxonomy which is sort of meaningless
and very confusing
good thanks a lot let's uh thank
the speaker again for a great
talk and
as this
is the last session before i hand over
to the organizers
i think we should really thank them for
this
meeting
and also bringing the culture in our
field back
the interaction the dinners and
everything so i think it's really been a
a nice
event
so i i leave from here in a very
uplifted way so thank you to
to you for that thanks
thank you very much sir
all right well it's already time to
conclude the workshop
i thought these four days actually went
by
really quickly especially after such a
long
anticipation more than two years right
or three years i think since the
planning
started so um
i was actually so impressed by the
quality of the talks and
the discussions in and outside of the
session
i thought there was remarkable breath
and impact
and the topics that are
being addressed and enough exciting
questions and challenges to keep us busy
for
several years to come if not decades
so we have a lively
thoughtful and thriving computational
biology community and certainly it's
certainly really nice like soren said to
get back the culture and spend time
together so so i'd like to thank first
of all the simon's institute for hosting
us
uh ron and stephen for um for setting up
the month program which we are this
workshop is a part of
um haiyan for graciously stepping up to
help with the organization and moderate
for being such a
wonderful co-organizer we're actually
saying on the way back from lunch today
that we should think about a way to
make this happen
again not just stop
at this time but make this more of a
recurring
event
so the workshop by site was
scientifically productive i think but
also is wonderful to be back in person
and catch up with people we haven't seen
in you know several years that people
we've known for decades
so last but not least
our heartfelt thanks
to all of you the the speakers and the
participants so for your invaluable
contributions
to the workshop and
keep in touch
safe travel and hope to see you soon
thank you
okay so
thanks uh
roderick and sabrina
it's really
great to see this actually happening
after all this long wait
[Music]
superb scientifically and otherwise
i thank the correct foundation
for
funding this
activity and the simons for the
organization and the hospitality
for those who are
staying around for the long program you
may have already
seen the email we continue the
activities there are
three uh
meeting next week on tuesday reading
group where the student will present on
thursday
martin vingron who is
joining the
long-term visitors we'll give a talk and
on friday we have a talk from an
illumina scientist and we have plans
also for the following week which will
be the last so thanks again for coming
and for those who are leaving have a
safe trip home
i just want to echo ron's comments and
thank all of you for your participation
meanwhile the the core of berkeley tel
aviv initiative continues beyond this
for another about year and a half we'll
have another round of grants which will
be open
this fall free to apply for those of you
from berkeley and tel aviv we encourage
you to participate and we'll have
another set of workshops
joined between the campuses going on
there and so um to sandrine's you know
thought how do we continue this that
that's something that we definitely hope
to continue that conversation and glad
to hear that you're enthusiastic to do
even more work for us after all these
years of
um putting this together so thank you
all very much and i look forward to
seeing you later today and for as long
as you stay here
and happy travels
[Music]
you